hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website calm today we are in round five
of our coverage of the 2017 Grand Prix
in Geneva our competitors whites going
to be played by Paola Liana we saw him
in round three had a very nice victory
with the white pieces his opponent plane
two black pieces alexander ganesha one
of the top players into the world and in
the grand prix circuit he's having a
good run so far in the the first leg of
the grand prix he tied for first in the
second leg he tied for third so a strong
showing here could lock up very easily a
top to finish and secure his spot in the
candidates tournament next year below
these players in this particular
tournament near the top of the
leaderboard so we're going to get
started with pawn to c4 don't see much
English opening but this could very well
turn into the Queen's game to climb line
as we've seen so much so far
Knight to c3 pawn down here to e4 and
then Knight to f3 so it does not look
like we're specifically going to get
into the Queen's begin to climb line
generally are going to be seeing the
pawn to e6 and then coming down here to
pawn to d5 which is me exactly what we
could have seen from white but this pawn
to e5 does change things a little bit
and then we get into the four Knights
game specifically the English opening
variation of the four Knights game which
is not often seen so there's not as much
theory particularly in at this opening
but always fun to watch players as they
kind of get into new theory openings in
the four Knights game is one of my
favorites so always good to kind of
commentate on these pawn to g3 getting
ready to fee in Canada Bishop to the
King side happens to see this quite
often when you played the English
opening from white pawn to d5 us really
trying to attack the center of the board
pawn takes on d5 anytime you can give up
your seat pawn from one of your
opponent's central pawns you're
generally going to be taking that knight
takes on d5 being Quetta on the King
side and then Bishop down here to c5
more common we'll just see the knight
coming here to b6 and then you know the
bishop has a few options of where he
wants to go before he castles on the
King side but instead decides to go
ahead and play Bishop down here to see
five and then castle on the King side
for white why could've definitely chose
another outside
hang on the kingside could have taken
with his night here on e5 it gets
somewhat complicated depending on how
both sides want to proceed in this
position most common languages see
Knight takes here on c3 but if black
tries to play something like Knight
takes on e5 well then the bishop could
just come up here take on d5 and then
really attacking this square here on f7
but if black wants to you know attack on
c6 then white could retreat if you
wanted to you could also play pawn to d4
attacking both the pieces if we want to
see the exchange on board you know
that's fine both sides can be pretty
aggressive if they want to that's not as
common instead you could see Knight
takes on c3 kind of baiting his opponent
as far as how he wants to continue this
is attacking the Queen here on d1 and
you may even see this in your own games
if you were to play the English opening
for Knights variation but it is saying
okay I'm going to take material down
here I don't want to get into any of
these situations where I'm going to take
your knight on 85 and then you're going
um up with your Bishop to d5 so I'm
going to take I'm going to attack your
Queen but didn't white to look at and
say yeah I'm going to take your knight
back I'm going to take your queen if you
don't take mine that's fine I'm going to
be up a pawn in material if you kind of
look at the exchange and how it went but
black has kind of an in-between move
we're kind of sorts White's attack and
that's Queen here to f6 and says I'm
still attacking your Queen but now I'm
threatening this Queen down here to F -
checkmate because of the Bishop on c5
and it gets a little tricky from here as
far as how white is going to continue if
if he doesn't just capture the knight
right here he's pretty much going to
lose his queen if you can't just move
his queen because then as we talked
about the Queen comes down here and it's
going to be checkmate because the knight
also attacks the squares for the King
Cain come over there to d1 so if you
were to take let's say pawn takes on c3
then Queen down here f2 King up here to
d2 really doesn't have any other options
can take that Bishop on g2 Knight d4
does not want to lose that material
maybe Bishop down here g4 you can start
to see the huge attack that black is
going to have here so why just decides
not I'm going to worry about any of
those very
I'm just going to play castle on the
kingside and we'll go from there
black decides to do the exact same and
then pawn to d3 opening up for his dark
squared Bishop you get involved into the
game but you're back here to a b6 and
then Knight over here to a4 not the most
common move do you know we're going to
be seeing Bishop to d2 another move that
I like any time I'm seeing this bishop
here to b6
I usually just automatically will play
pawn to e2 a 4 unless I see something
just looks a lot better so let's put
more pressure on your opponent usually
going to be forcing them to play this
pawn to a6 bringing their bishop back
here to a7 I think that's fine it allows
me to continue with an attack on the
Queen side abort if he doesn't you know
can always play that pawn to a5 10 a lot
of times you can steal some some free
material depending on where your
opponent is going to be going from there
so after we see the knight coming over
here to a4 rook over here - eh black
besides I'm not going to worry about
that Bishop if you want to exchange on
board that's going to be fun I'm just
going to have a semi-open file for my
rook to attack that's going to be fine
for Black Keys he says so rook over here
to e8 a bishop up here g5 attacking the
Queen kind of had two options here you
can play pawn to f6 to stop that that
does weaken his King side of the board
so decides to go ahead and not do that
and play Queen here to d6 doesn't want
to allow his LightSquared bishop to get
outside and start to attack doesn't want
to block it off here with Queen to d7
that kind of defeats the purpose of his
opening preparation Knight back here to
d2 so wipe doesn't really have his nice
position in the center of the board
controlling black definitely has a more
active position White's really trying to
maneuver his minor pieces around to gain
control or right now blacks doing a good
job of controlling with the pieces he
has Queen over here to a g6 if we come
back here you know he played Knight here
to D tube if he were to take with his
knight let's say on b6 it's just not as
good he is he would like pawn takes on
b6 pawn a3 maybe pawn h6 forcing the
bishop come back here bishop down g4 you
can really start to see the pressure
that blacks putting on his
so white decides to just bring his
knight back here to g2 but after queen
g6 night up to e4 and then Bishop down
to g4 threatening the night also coming
to d4 and putting more pressure on the
square on YouTube why continues with
pawn to h3 forcing the bishop back here
and that's that's fine I think from
black any time your opponent fianchetto
on one side of board if you can get them
to start to push their other pawns
forward that really starts to weaken
their King defense and you can maybe get
behind enemy lines start to chip away or
their pawns are usually a little bit
unprotected they sometimes will have to
bring their King to protect those and
you can start to attack that as well
Bishop comes back here to d2 recover
here to d8 to doing a job of controlling
the semi-open file in the center of the
board
White's not really doing too much with
his rooks at some point he could bring
his recovery here to c1 try to control
the semi open file hasn't decided to do
that yet
King h2 protecting some of his material
on the King sided board King to AJ don't
know they necessarily has to play King
to h8 but decided to play a little bit
more conservative maybe he wants to
start throwing some of these pawns at
the king's head the board since he does
have more of control to sort of the
board and starting to attack on the King
side as well pawn to e3 pawn down here
to f5 so being aggressive on board even
after his King to H a cuz if we come
back even F to the King day J he could
just play pawn h-hi then super
aggressive start to push he does have
his Bishop he could easily get his
knight over there if you wanted to but
decides let's take a move off but then
after pawn to f5 you can definitely see
the addition looking to be pretty
aggressive on board
nice to see five bishop back here to see
eight and then pawn up to Abby for
there's a few ways that he could have
protected you know his position he
already has this nice on a four I think
he could have easily played rook here to
see one get his rook to very active
square protect the the night if he wants
to not sure that pawn to b4 is the
strategy that you really wanted to play
because pawn to e4 is very very tricky
for his opponent for us how how you
proceed you know if you kind of look at
this and
a what is why do now why could just take
if you wanted to there's complications
in this position play we're over here to
see one if you wanted to
Queen to see to try to protect this he
does have his knife and this pawn here
as well protecting this this square but
it gets a little bit tricky if he
doesn't protect that could also try
something else he decided to choose pawn
to e3 which I think has its own
complications on board we see the
exchange Bishop takes the knight on c5
after the Knight takes pawn here to b6
forcing the knight back and then Bishop
to a6 and this is now threatening the
pawn and the bishop attacking the pawn
it's kind of tough to find that in the
position as you're looking at and say
where does white go
he plays pawn to e3 it doesn't look that
dangerous but actually with the
continuation that black finds it's
actually pretty pretty tough for white
to kind of continue after the knight
comes back here Bishop a6 and then
Knight back here to see one protecting
this so if you look at both sides you
can clearly see White's force to bring
his knight back here to see one just to
protect a pond deep and inside of the
board he doesn't have good king sized
protection and blacks are starting to
throw everything you can his opponent
you can see it more and more after every
single move Knight here to e5 putting
even more pressure on the square on a d3
Queen up to a4 just trying to get some
of his pieces active on board but then
the bishop takes getting a material
advantage Knight takes on d3 and this is
an outpost it's going to be very
difficult for white to deal with it's
it's going to be a few moves where you
can even get his Bishop over here to
exchange on board this pawn right here
with a good pawn structure is not going
anywhere kind of blocking off this
Bishop form even going in where so kind
of limits the squares that white has you
can just feel that White's in a tough
spot if you can get a draw from this
this would be a huge victory I think for
white but black just has a huge
dominating presence on board right now
why continues upon to b5 pawn over here
to h5 started attack the Kings has a
board Queen c2 Queen over here to d6
I think because he has this Queen on g6
I think you may even want to just
pressure with pawn to h4 this really
starts to put pressure he wants to take
care is just opening up the door to
attack even more but decides to go and
play Queen over here to d6 this does
also pin down the pawn not that the pawn
is going to be moving too much because
he doesn't want a week at his King side
even more it also does threaten this
pawn on each on a3 if the rook decides
to move maybe you want to come over here
to see one double up so we can start to
attack the seventh rank from black pawn
to h4 so says I don't want this pawn
coming down here to h4 so I'm going to
go ahead and stop that right here pawn
to h4 Queen down here if I've just
centralizing a little bit more now
attacking the rook here on a1 King back
here a g1 rook to e6 so starting to move
his pieces we can use those rooks maybe
on a King side attack the the center of
the board is kind of blocked off and
that's five you know blacks own doing
but he doesn't really want to get rid of
that because you have such a strong
presence with its pawns in his night
here on d3 so he's going to be looking
to use his knife somewhere else on the
board pawn to a4 King here to h7 rook
here to a3 rook to d6 just doubling up I
can start to swing over if you want to
first wants to kind of figure out what's
going on the Queen side the board Ponte
j5y doesn't have much going on the King
side says I'll just try my best effort
on the Queen side of the board pawn down
to c5 and then pawn takes on t6 now if I
can't look at this say that's not a
legal move it actually is called on
pissant if you are on the fifth rank as
White's and your opponent's plays two
moves here then you have one move one
move only to capture it like this it
does look kind of weird if you haven't
seen it before but trust me it's legal
rook takes on c6 attacking the Queen
Queens force moved back here to d1 now
nice to f6 what's really nice in these
positions when all the actions on one
side of board nice actually do a lot
better because they can position
themselves in really interesting places
where bishops are kind of get blocked
off this light square bishop is not
doing
anything this dark square bishop could
definitely be in a better position but
it's not doing much at all because it's
not really that open of a game so black
not only is up material but he's also up
material that's relevant in the game
Weiss is kind of sitting there doing a
whole heck of a lot of nothing the rook
here on f1 is not moving rook on a3
that's not really really where you want
your rook so all in all it's going to be
tough for whites to come out of this
pawn takes pawn recaptures now there's a
path pawn that White's going to have to
worry about as well but that's not even
really what the game is about just more
pressure on white is what black is going
to be going for rook to d6 so work is
completely controlling the C and the D
files as well rook to b3
that's fine says if you want to go ahead
and attack this I have both my rooks I'm
going to go ahead and worry about my
knight coming over here to g4 add more
pressure
Bishop to before sure get to dark square
bishop balled into the game issues way
too late though is just not going to do
anything rooked here to d5 Bishop e1
just trying to play defense but then
after rook down to c1 we see a
resignation from white there's just too
much pressure there's no way out of this
any line he continues is going to be a
losing one so decides to go ahead and
resign
Alexander GLIAC congratulations to him
moving up towards the top of the
leaderboard so a really good tournament
for him he's really looking for to
solidify and just lock this up knowing
that he's not playing in the last leg of
the Grand Prix he wants to kind of
ensure himself now that he's going to be
going to the candidates tournament so
congratulations to him thank you guys
for watching around 5 we do have a day
off tomorrow the players have a rest day
and they come back for four additional
rounds as we'll be covering one game
from each of those rounds thanks again
for watching I'll see you guys in round
6